z prędkością światła nadganiamy to
na co kraje europy zachodniej potrzebowały 40 50 lat
proszę państwa
w niemczech afd
notabene nie wiem czy pan tak to zauważył
ale piszą polskie media my streamowe
że afd jest zagrożeniem dla polski
afd jest zagrożeniem dla polski
o proszę w związku z tym
że afd jest 2. siłą policzną
już w niemczech jest zagrożeniem dla polski
i uwaga i uwaga i uwaga
no jakżeby inaczej mogło nie mogli się oprzeć
są w konfederacji siły
które się z nimi spotykają
te też są ta dam tak
są w konfederacji siły
które twierdzą tak Jak afd
tak Jak afd są przeciwko migracji
przeciwko aborcji
są są przeciwko brukseli
unii europejskiej
są takie siły w konfederacji więc
migracja w niemczech doprowadziła do tego
i w yy krajach europy zachodniej
że mamy bardzo poważną sytuację
2/3 niemców szanowni państwo nie czuję się bezpiecznie
2/3 języków i czuję się bezpiecznie w berlinie
na stacjach kolejki
na stacjach metra
policja przepisami na wyznaczonych wprowadza
zakaz przemieszczania się z narzędziami kłującymi
tak to nawet może być widelec
moi drodzy Jak macie plastikowy to może nie
jest tak źle Jak nigdy jeszcze nie było
a co mamy w polsce
nanoszowi państwo
wzrost kradzieży
wzrost napadów
duży wzrost wzrost gwałtów tak mhm
no ale oczywiście
oczywiście nie wolno
i nie można to już powtórzam tu Po raz kolejny
znowu w kierunku pana redaktora
powtarzać tych kłamstw
że jest to związane z migracją